about sixty nine percent of americans
said that they had shopped around for a
higher-quality less expensive auto
insurance policy and a similar
percentage said they would like to have
that ability in the health insurance
market today
I am Nicholas B with reason TV and today
we're talking with Emily Ekins director
polling at Reason Foundation we've got
our latest reason-rupe pull out a
national poll that's looking at all
sorts of stuff we focused on health care
and the new health care that was passed
by President Obama let's look at some of
the results you note that about fifty
percent of Americans have an unfavorable
opinion towards the new health care law
about thirty two percent have a
favorable opinion of the health care law
what what more can we say about that
what we found is that the law does not
enjoy a great deal of support right now
about fifty percent just say we should
repeal it and sixty-two percent believe
it's unconstitutional and that is mostly
when they say it's unconstitutional are
they talking about the individual
mandate part yes they're they're talking
about the part of the provision in the
law that work that Congress requires
individuals to obtain health insurance
or else pay a fine and we find that
likely the the opposition to the health
care law is probably driven by
opposition to this particular provision
however when we ask about some of the
other provisions in the health care law
we actually find support for those
provisions a lot of polls ask about
explicit provisions in the law but they
don't tend to ask about the potential
costs so they'll say something like do
you think everybody should be covered
but then they don't say do you think
everybody should be covered even if it
increases your premium by a hundred
percent or whatever exactly and it's
understandable why that's the case
because it's hard to know what could
potentially occur as a result of these
provisions so we asked about a few one
in particular we asked about community
rating which prohibits health insurance
companies from charging higher rates to
some customers on the basis of medical
history or pre-existing conditions so we
asked about this we find what most polls
find that there's majority support for
this provision fifty-two percent of
americans favor this provision however
we know that a slim majority of
americans don't want people with bad
medical conditions to have to pay more
for health insurer if it were the case
that this provision resulted in higher
taxes would you favor or oppose this
provision support actually drops to
about thirty seven percent then we asked
if it were to result in higher premiums
support also drops to about forty
percent and if we asked about increased
wait times you know wait times to see
your doctor support also decreases but
when we asked about if this provision
Community Rating were to result in lower
quality health care opposition
skyrockets to seventy-six percent so it
appears that people aren't too thrilled
with higher taxes or higher premiums but
there is maybe some room for negotiation
but when it comes to quality of
healthcare this is something people are
not ready to know to sacrifice or to
negotiate and you found that it was
something like fifty 86 around sixty
percent of Americans are satisfied with
their current health care and that seems
to be the main sticking point if
anything changes that decreases the
quality of their care they'll be very
upset correct part of what you found is
that about six around sixty percent of
Americans are satisfied with their
health care and they seem to be upset at
the notion that anything might change
that would reduce the quality of their
health care by the same token they are
not particularly aware of how heavily
regulated the health care market is can
you talk a little bit about the dis
juncture between people's understanding
of the quality of health care and the
way the health care system actually
works yes we asked a few questions about
regulation in the health care market we
found that about a third of Americans
thought it was very regulated a third
thought it was just you know somewhat
regulated and another third thought it
wasn't very regulated at all then we
asked well as it regulated too much to
the extent that it is regulated about
forty percent said it wasn't regulated
enough and you know another third said
it wasn't it was regulated too much and
some thought it was about right this
shows a disjuncture between what is
actually happening in the health care
market is it regulated a lot or just a
little and and what does that mean
for you know reforming the health care
market because clearly there are
problems there are ways that we should
be looking to improve it and it's hard
to move forward if people aren't clear
as to what the market currently looks
like and you said that people don't
really have a sense of strong
competition within the health care
market or the idea of making choices
that's correct about forty two percent
of americans said that they that they
did not believe they had a choice in
health insurance providers and to show
some contrast to this sixty-eight
percent about sixty-nine percent of
americans said that they had shopped
around for a higher-quality less
expensive auto insurance policy and a
similar percentage said they would like
to have that ability in the health
insurance market today however it that
isn't really possible the way the
structure is set today the bottom line
of the health care findings of the
reason roof Pole is really that people
are generally satisfied with their
health care as it stands that's right
that's correct that also that people
don't know all that much about their
health care or how it's delivered yeah
and that they are very skittish about
anything that would drive quality down
correct so in a final point in the poll
that says or you found that something
like fifty five percent of americans are
in favor of giving compensation to organ
donors can you talk a little bit about
that we asked about whether or not if an
individual wanted to donate an organ
under medical supervision to another
individual who needed it what would
would we be allowed to compensate that
person and although under current law
this isn't allowed fifty-five percent of
americans think it should be legal to
financially compensate someone emily
ekins director of polling at Reason
Foundation I want to thank you for
talking to reason TV today we have our
new reason-rupe poll we're going to just
that we're going to be rolling out the
results of that over the next few days
and weeks thank you very much for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie